who are your uh you know growing up in
Brooklyn who are your who are your goats
who are you like uh who's on the wall
for you uh you got Kim you got Fox Jay-Z
biggie those are good four yeah it is
Uncle Maya Uncle may but that's bias
though Uncle Mayo know that Mayo's first
album is one of the most slept on albums
ever Uncle Mayo is slept on period unle
that first album it's a [__] the
whole album's a concept it's literally
like one of the hardest concept albums
he gets out of jail the whole album is
about him getting out of jail and
there's just that album so crazy the
story I feel like every artist need
story hard oh shout out to Mayo shout
outs to Uncle Mayo I love you I just
booked him my TT he was at my club like
two days ago Phoenix with my guy mkhs
out there yeah he had fun right I'm sure
he's you know he's a fun my boy have fun
he's a fun guy he is super fun guy shout
out to Mayo um so you said what's your
favorite Foxy Brown
project uh honestly for me I'm not a a
project type of girl I'm like a single
so Brooklyn Anthem was that was what
made me be like I'm this way for a
reason she's a Brooklyn girl like
there's nothing wrong with me I used to
think that I was too aggressive people
always say you so aggressive you so this
you so that and then foxy made me
realize like no I'm not you know foxy
was aggressive as [__] yeah so I'm like
no I'm not I'm just from she was a part
of the firm yo like you know what I'm
saying like she was like holding her own
with Nas and AZ consistently yeah so the
thing for me is see I wouldn't say that
I grew up on Kim and Foxy music but I'm
from Brooklyn so that's like I had to
know who biggie was Kim Fox like I just
had to know so yeah I'm a student in a
game so I tap in and I study it but no I
didn't necessarily grow up on the music
like you know that makes sense um do you
have a name for your fan base Gators the
Gators yeah the Gators uhuh uh wow are
they
toxic cuz I'm not toxic though no I'm
just saying some of these fan bases get
a little aggressive I've had little kids
folks come at me they're pretty crazy I
I'm not going to front though they might
go crazy on you if you like the Gators
yeah if you don't if you don't if you
growl at me they going to growl back
what does that mean oh like like hm yeah
the death r g the death row cuz yeah the
death row what you mean why Gators
because my my skin is bulletproof so I'm
big Gator it just came about I did a
freestyle on a platform shout out to I95
I did a freestyle shout out to those
guys bar on I95 I was like 2020 I ain't
giving out no favors my skin bulletproof
[__] I'm big Gator and then my fans
would just take it and be like big Gator
big Gator big Gator but before I tapped
into it I'm like can I really relate to
this name regardless of the skin being
bulletproof and I can because they very
patient and they they um warmhearted but
cold bloody have you had fans show up to
your shows wearing Florida Gator merch
like gear no like atbo Jersey like look
Gators you know no I don't I don't think
so I don't think so I don't think I ever
caught that before you got to go to
Gainesville now I do Gainesville Florida
is where the Florida show me mad love
though like I have a good fan base in
Florida though where where in Florida
have you performed um Orlando
uh
Miami Miami is nice somewhere else have
you been to the strip clubs in Miami yet
booby trap booby trap's a movie it's
also un it's almost unbearable booby
trap is a real thing when you're in
booby tra you're really trapped and you
can't leave and I don't like to party
but when you don't want to leave the
Ubers are taking forever to get there
there's a line outside it's [__] 7 in
the morning I'm tired I'm miserable
Miser you be what you I I mean after
pulling an all nighter and I'm on
[__] jet from the West Coast n and
then you're with this guy DJ AO he's a
psychopath good guy though I'm sure
you've met him I had a time in my life
at booby trap I couldn't believe I a
want to leave my team kept saying you
ready to go you spend a lot of money you
oh no I didn't no I didn't no I don't do
those type of things did you eat did I
they got they got food at booby trap I'm
I don't remember they got some of the
best strip club food in the country is
in Florida Miami specifically G5 has
great wings um uncle trick uh made sure
he fed me when I came out there his food
was really fed you what did he cook cuz
you know he cook I mean he got he got a
he got a spot I didn't know that yeah he
got a restaurant was it good it's called
Uh Sunday's what um Sunday eer Sunday I
remember I think he was on Cribs or some
show cooking some wild [__] you remember
that yeah he
shout trick Florida like pancake thing
he was cooking no I had some turkey
wings turkey wings did I what it yeah I
had some turkey wings uh are those
bigger than chicken wings it was fire
I've had a turkey leg I've never had a
turkey wing at like a rest turkey no I
mean that's why you got that restaurant
because I got to go I've only been to
like a finger licking which in my
household turkey wings was a thing but
not for me I didn't like turkey wings
until I got older you got to go to
tootsies and get the fried lobster tail
while a lady massages you they have a
they have non strippers there what type
of freaky eer is that no no no it's
toies tootsies is a legendary strip club
you know Drake said I'm toot shoulder
rubs I've never I've never been there so
tootsies they have dancers and then they
have literal fully clothed lady like
masseuses so like some someone's Auntie
is in there like they'll rub your back
for like 45 minutes for or 45 bucks I
think it's for 30 minutes or something
like that or it's 45 bucks for 15
minutes and it's amazing so you're just
sitting there eating maybe the fight's
on maybe the Dolphins are playing and
then you got a lady giving you a real
massage like a real massage it's not
like no weirdo [__] like it's a real
Mass
oh really survive yeah oh I got to go
it's it's not a bad place I got to go
but booby trap is a movie for sure yeah
booby trap is a trap for sure you know
what I noticed when you go to the strip
club in New York it's more about the
bartenders than it is the
dancers is that fair oh that's a New
York thing yeah that's a New York thing
right yeah like bartenders might get
more love than strippers for sure yeah m